I want you to imagine that you're a
child protective service worker and you
have to respond to a report of child
abuse you walk into a home unannounced
unexpected certainly uninvited the first
thing you see is a mattress in the
middle of the room on the floor three
kids lying on it asleep there's a small
table nearby with a couple of ashtrays
empty beer cans large rat traps are set
in the corner not too far from where the
kids lie asleep so you make a note a
part of your job is walking through the
entire home so you start with the
kitchen where there's very little food
you notice another mattress in the
bedroom on the floor that the mother
shares with her infant child now
generally at this point two things may
happen the children are deemed unsafe
and removed from the home and placed in
state custody for a specified period of
time or the children remain with their
family and the child welfare system
provides help and support when I was a
child protective service worker I saw
things like this all the time
some far better some far worse I asked
you to imagine yourself in that home
because I wonder what crossed your mind
what guides your decisions what's going
to impact your opinion of that family
what race/ethnicity did you think the
family was I want you to realize that if
those children were white it is more
likely that their family stays together
after that visit research done at the
University of Pennsylvania found that
white families on average have access to
more help and more support from the
child welfare system and their cases are
less likely to go through a full
investigation
but on the other hand if those kids are
black they are four times more likely to
be removed they spend longer periods of
time in foster care and it's harder to
find them a stable foster placement
foster care is meant to be an immediate
shelter of protection for kids who are
at high risk but it's also a confusing
and traumatic exit from the family
research done at the University of
Minnesota found that kids who went
through foster care had more behavioral
problems and internalized issues than
kids who remain with their families
while receiving help and support the
scenario I mentioned earlier is not
uncommon a single mother living in
low-income housing with her four
children and the rats make it almost
impossible to keep food let alone fresh
food in the home does that mother
deserve to have her children taken from
her Emma Kettering ham a family court
attorney says that if you live in a poor
neighborhood then you better be a
perfect parent she says that we place
unfair often unreachable standards on
parents who are raising their kids with
very little money and their neighborhood
and ethnicity impact whether or not
their kids are removed in the two years
I spent on the front lines of child
welfare I made high-stakes decisions and
I saw firsthand how my personal values
impacted my work now as Social Work
faculty at Florida State University I
lead an institute that curates the most
innovative and effective child welfare
research and research tells us that
there are twice as many black kids in
foster care
28% then there are in the general
population 14% and although there are
several reasons why I want to discuss
one reason today implicit bias let's
start with implicit it's subconscious
something you're not aware of bias those
stereotypes and attitudes that we all
have about certain groups of people so
implicit bias is what lurks in the
background of every decision that we
make
so how can we fix it I have a promising
solution that I want to share now in
almost every state there are high
numbers of black kids going into foster
care but data revealed that Nassau
County a community in New York had
managed to decrease the number of black
kids being removed and in 2016 I went
into that community with my team and led
a research study discovering the use of
blind removal meetings this is how it
works a caseworker responds to a report
of child abuse they go out to the home
but before the children are removed the
caseworker must come back to the office
and present what they found but here's
the distinction when they present to the
committee they delete names ethnicity
neighborhood race all identifiable
information they focus on what happened
family strength relevant history and the
parents ability to protect the child
with that information the committee
makes a recommendation never knowing the
race of the family blind removals have
made a drastic impact in that community
in 2011 57 percent of the kids going
into foster care were black but after
five years of blind removals that is
down to 21 percent
here's what we learn from talking to
some of the caseworkers when a family
has a history with the department many
of us hold that history against them
even if they're trying to do things
differently when I see a case from a
certain apartment building neighborhood
or zip code I just automatically think
the worst child welfare is very
subjective because it's an emotional
field there's no one who doesn't have
emotions around this work and it's very
hard to leave all of your stuff at the
door when you do this work so let's take
the subjectivity of race and
neighborhood out of it and you might get
different outcomes blind removals seem
to be bringing us closer to solving the
problem of implicit bias and foster care
decisions my next step is figuring out
how to use artificial intelligence and
machine learning to bring this project
to scale and make it more accessible to
other states I know we can transform
child welfare we can hold organizations
accountable to developing the social
consciousness of their employees we can
hold ourselves accountable to making
sure our decisions are driven by ethics
and safety let's imagine a child welfare
system that focuses on partnering with
parents empowering families and no
longer see poverty as failure let's work
together to build a system that wants to
make families stronger instead of
pulling them apart thank you
[Applause]